it was the first time that women saw a
movie that was directed specifically to
them you know the whole all the outlaw
movies all the great movies that have
ever been done
they've never captured that thing the
thing I was looking for as a writer and
as a filmmaker you know the experience
that I felt like I was missing in the
movie theater I tried to create it's
it's nothing that we realized at the
time I mean none of us strike a nerve
the way it did you know we were turned
down by quite a few Studios and you
really had to sit down and really read
the script and get it it had this sort
of mythic quality to it and it was funny
and it holds up the major hurdle was
that I'd never written anything before
and and I asked a friend of mine to
produce it with me for me to direct and
we started looking for money and one
person gave it to another person until
it ended up where it ended up with
Ridley Scott and at that point I stepped
aside as the director and let him do his
magic and we then passed Gina and Suzan
to me we're like perfect I mean you just
couldn't imagine the movie with anybody
about them so it was kind of like faith
I think we had the advantage of having a
very good chemistry together and really
really enjoy each other's company and
enjoy each other's acting so I think it
was a pretty natural phenomenon for us
to really work off each other also
Ridley does something very interesting
which is incredibly helpful for actors
if he shoots the close-ups at the same
time unless nobody does that because
lighting and whatever you know you're
you're both really in it when you're
doing a time it helped a lot there's an
outlaw movie you know and you had two
women in the roles that would ordinarily
be played by men and they were angry and
they were beautiful and they were sexy
and they were funny and they were good
with guns and they acted like their men
act in movies it had never really been
done before but I think it was the sense
of liberty and exhilaration that it gave
I think the idea that you could take
control of your own life to such an
extreme degree you know and never give
in I think that was very exciting and
empowering to me
you